so this map is quite convoluted it's
pretty complex than that
but I just mind my own shop in the back
ah that's made my day I left shanked
okay oh let's go Travis down up down
Travis Travis Travis my 20 where Travis
is the last round Oh Blanco's will be
giving away Xbox one no but who knows
was that guy there that whole time yeah
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] let's game
like he ponders mouse seen anyone yeah
it's basically if the room ghillie suits
man they can just labels punches she's
got her sights on destroyed the SATCOM
still my cup yeah you know he's gonna
wonder that one side you smoked it I
just keep pushing the right hand side so
we can get them on the left hands Waka I
think I found my home he smokes it boys
as well good after I don't even know how
I did that to us boy hello I'm in the
position now I'm ready to just drop
bombs do that beefcakes being Aaron
wouldn't kill with melee where shots
that were just out to get us merely kill
my gosh the nearest bush ave starts
playing writer oh my god I've got a
package me we're squirrel through the or
and poor poor shot through the care
package done what are you doing there
that's somebody's obscure part of the
map pinner yes you got it yeah how do I
go invisible invisible oh yeah walks on
you can shoulder cannon people wait I'm
dead self-destruct or while you're there
all dead though I've got the field
orders while kill one kill was jump
that's insane so you take it when you
think it's much damage is gay they get a
self-destruct